let's take a look at how sound works say
a bird starts singing and this travels
through the air as a sound wave before
reaching the ear the sound wave is an
analog signal but in order to represent
it on a computer we need to convert it
to digital information after its
converted to digital we might want to
perform some audio transforms on it
change the volume for apply some other
echo effect or something much more
complicated and awesome we can think of
all these transforms as a graph of
processing nodes that each transform our
sound in some way and you can put them
together then that's exactly how Web
Audio is structured in this case you can
take the sound and run it through a
series of nodes to transform it into for
example a slap back echo effect let's
take a look at the web audio playground
which is a web application built by
Chris Wilson it's a great way to
visualize how web audio works and you
can actually play around with all the
different nodes you can create source
nodes and add all these different
processing nodes to your sound and you
can create that same slapback effect
like this now Web Audio is a node graph
that is contained in something called an
audio context everything in the audio
context is run natively in high
performance code specifically designed
for audio processing of course what we
see here is a simple example a real node
graph may look quite complicated but
ultimately it's all using the same
concepts